vous appréciez humainement vous le savez
mais franchement vous devenez sulfureux
aller à l'anniversaire de jean marie le
pen faire une photo avec dieudonné
dieudonné c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas
fréquentable c'est quelqu'un qui a été
condamné
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça et ça ça m'a
profondément choqué lui a entièrement
raison et j'ai fait une erreur qui est
jeu voilà c'est j'ai vraiment fait une
erreur mais tu sais ça faisait trois
mois j'étais confiné j'avais ce projet
d'émission de télévision avec catherine
barma pas l'emilien productrice mais
voilà je devais j'ai rencontré à rome et
rue j'ai rencontré brigitte macro enfin
ans j'ai rencontré plein de gens c'est
dans l'année et donc moi on me propose
d'ailleurs anniversaire de la bungee
c'est super on va enfin pouvoir des gens
et je vais rester dix minutes j'ai
vraiment pas vu ah bah non c'est pas
notre quand même laissé mais j'ai fait
et je vais à ça tu as entièrement raison
je n'y retournerai plus n'ont pas non
plus la soirée de l'année passée et
honnêtement moi j'ai où on se connaît
moi j'ai vu un peu c'est vrai que moi
j'y arrivais renouvelle jean marie le
pen mais c'était pour lui un cadre mais
qui souhaitent aller fouiller votre
copain dieu devient super longtemps et
voilà enfin il faut assumer
on peut assumer la vous êtes là bas on
comprend pas jambes lundi à une ambiance
si jean marie le pen on m'appelle on dit
à une grosse soirée chez jean marie le
pen
bah ouais activa forêts ces jeux pal
quand ça s'est passé pourquoi m et
ramène toi abordait la sainte le fire
j'aime les dinosaures je me suis dit
c'est pas faut rencontrer c'est quand
même intéressant
non mais qu'est ce qu'elle est et foot à
soyhières comment tu l'as fait trouver
l'anniversaire de jean marie le peuple
bassa il n'a pas été invité par écoute
ça a duré 10 minutes et puis sur sûr
partie d'ailleurs et après l'invitation
et bien nous s'était incrusté nom m'a
invité mais qu'est ce qui m'a invité et
ben c'est le pen parce que le pen à
regarde l'émission l'émission à faire
conclut aidons les jeunes aguerris n'ont
quoi ben écoute j'ai beaucoup de choses
à acheter chez lui d'ailleurs il avait
donc et donc et appelle celui que tu
appelles non non non mais c'est vrai
qu'est-ce que vous allez [ __ ] cette
année derrière j'ai fait une connerie
j'aurais pas dû j'aurais dû accepter
d'aller chez line renaud sort a été plus
drôle c'est clair